Уже за лічені хвилини - у саме "пекло" бахмутського напрямку
- поїде ось цей пікап.
По нього у Київ з фронту приїхали військові ЗСУ,
які місяць тому втратили одну зі своїх автівок.
Якраз на мені й закінчилася машина.
Пригнали нам Nissan Navara, буквально тиждень,
це другий її виїзд був, і ми потрапили під артобстріл.
І залишили машину. Відступали пішки. Залишили машину,
БК була у нас. Буквально тиждень вона у нас пробула.
Тільки-тільки її загнали, все зробили, замінили мастила,
все зробили, щоб вона їздила, і так трапилось,
що вона у нас на другому ж виїзді лишилася там, у Бахмуті.
Забрати машину з Бахмута так і не вдалося.
Там дуже був масований обстріл. Кілька діб він був.
Тобто там техніка мало їздила, щоб забрати.
І така ситуація типова. У середньому на фронті автівки "живуть"
від трьох до п'яти тижнів, розповідають військові.
Це такий швидкий ресурс, який закінчується швидко.
Бо самі дороги погані, і ми їздимо на великій швидкості там
на небезпечних ділянках. І багато їх іде на ремонт.
Дуже багато ремонтуємо.
Без автівок на війні не обійтися.
Саме тому волонтери, благодійні організації та й самі
військові щоденно оголошують збори коштів
на машини для ЗСУ.
Нині на фронті найбільш затребувані пікапи та джипи.
Лише торік для ЗСУ з-за кордону ввезли понад 60 тисяч автівок.
Такі дані наводять у Державній митній службі.
І цьогоріч запитів не менше. А на тлі ймовірного
контрнаступу ці потреби зростуть в рази.
Ми обрали саме Ford F-250 та F-350 для наших військових,
тому що, по-перше, ці авто дизельні.
Це 6-літрові дизельні двигуни.
Авто мають повний привід і дуже велику в своєму класі
вантажопідйомність. F-250, наприклад,
бере на себе півтори тонни навантаження,
а F-350 Ford десь дві з половиною тонни бере.
У цих автівок високий кліренс. Вони дуже витривалі,
у них мільйонники двигуни. У них грязьова гума
встановлюється нами на кожну автівку.
Олександр керує проєктом "ГЕРОЙCAR",
у рамках якого разом з командою збирає запити
на машини від ЗСУ, проводить верифікацію заявок,
організовує збір коштів і поставки автівок з усього світу.
Ці "форди" ми веземо тільки з Америки,
їх більше ні на одному ринку немає, саме дизельних таких машин.
Деякі автівки ми веземо з Європи, наприклад, Volkswagen T4.
З Кореї ми веземо SsangYong.
Вже закуплені перші автівки, теж пікапи.
Бо не всім військовим потрібні дуже великі пікапи.
Розвідка, наприклад, потребує невеличких пікапів
з повним приводом, дизельних. Ми веземо такі автівки з Кореї.
Закуповують переважно вживані автівки,
адже вони значно дешевші. Тож перед покупкою
їх ретельно перевіряють. Адже від технічного стану машин
залежить життя українських військових.
Усі в статусі run and drive, тобто вона заводиться і їде.
Далі, коли авто приїжджає в Україну, ми повністю робимо
технічне обслуговування автівки. Ми міняємо мастила всі,
ми міняємо всі фільтри, ми рідини всі міняємо в автівці.
Ми автівки перевзуваємо на нову гуму,
ми міняємо акумулятори. Більш того, ми розраховуємо так,
щоб автівка не менше як 30-50 тисяч кілометрів
пройшла без суттєвих ремонтів.
Ремонтувати тільки-но придбані машини
допомагає український бізнес.
Приміром, партнерами проєкту стали приватні станції
технічного обслуговування. На одній з таких в Києві
щоденно кипить робота.
У даному випадку в нас будуть виконуватися роботи
із заміни насоса на цьому Ford 250,
на сусідній машині зняли вікна.
Зараз замовляється броньоване скло,
тобто буде укріплятися ця машина.
Машини для ЗСУ на СТО обслуговують зі знижками,
а деякі послуги надають й безкоштовно.
Діагностичні роботи практично робимо безкоштовно,
а на ремонти робимо 20% знижку.
Наприклад, якщо виконується ремонт на 10 тисяч гривень,
2 тисячі гривень знижка буде на проведення ремонту.
На партнерських СТО також ремонтують пошкоджені
машини з фронту. Та у більшості випадків автівки,
які вже побували на війні, ремонту не підлягають.
Нині такі машини на вулицях Києва стоять як експонати.
Більшість людей не розуміє, навіщо машини в такій кількості
для фронту. Вони не розуміють. Одне діло бачити
в телевізорі розстріляну машину, інше діло підійти
і зрозуміти, якщо ти б там сидів або хтось сидів поряд
з тобою в ній, що б він відчував, що б він бачив…
І взагалі подивитися на цю автівку, що вона не може
бути відремонтована. Більшість автівок на фронті
гинуть через 3-5 тижнів до такого стану,
що просто хлопці, які залишилися живі, виходять з неї
і просто прямують далі пішки.
Саме тому збори коштів не припиняються ні на мить.
Військові ЗСУ потребують дедалі нових машин.
І для закриття цих потреб щоденно працюють сотні волонтерів
по всій Україні. Приміром, в СТО на околицях Одеси
до відправлення на фронт готують ось ці пікапи.
Серед тутешніх волонтерів - чемпіон світу з дрифту Дмитро Іллюк.
Спортсмен шукає придатні автівки по всій Європі.
Часом машини знаходять Іллю самі.
Була ситуація, коли в морпіхів зламалося авто Subaru,
і немає сенсу ремонтувати двигун.
Тільки ми ввечері бачимо, що вони лишаються без автівки,
як пише людина й каже: "У мене в Кишиневі є машина,
я хочу її задонатити для ЗСУ".
Купувати та переробляти автівки волонтери
почали восени 2022 року. Багато в чому допомагають
спортивні зв'язки Іллі по всьому світу.
Я звернувся до своїх друзів по автоспорту з Англії.
І в Англії нам знайшли першу автівку.
Поки вони знайшли першу автівку, там ми вже знайшли
другу, третю, четверту. Так трапилося,
що в Англії за один раз ми купили чотири автівки.
Часто першими до волонтерів звертаються самі військові.
Якщо коштів на авто бракує - волонтери
допомагають їм зібрати необхідну суму й головне
- знайти придатну машину.
Стосовно автівок з Європи: багато людей на цьому
заробляють гроші. Вони купують металобрухт,
іржавий, котрий вже не придатний для використання.
На жаль, такі автівки привозять, вони нічого не коштують,
а потім їх тут передають військовим, а вони розвалюються.
А ми вибираємо автівку, яка має дійсний техогляд.
У Німеччині дуже жорсткий контроль,
тому майже нічого не треба робити з автівками.
Останні штрихи - й автівка для військової частини,
в якій служить Олег, майже готова.
Той підрозділ, в якому я служу, це такі малі групи,
які пересуваються. От є завдання виїхати в якесь місце,
і треба по пересіченій місцевості максимально
швидко пересуватися. Тому такі пікапи дуже зручні.
Адже частина відділення може сидіти в самій машині,
а частина зі зброєю й амініцією можуть бути на багажнику.
Кошти на цю автівку Олег з побратимами збирав
серед друзів і знайомих у соцмережах.
Її пригнали з Англії. Приблизно це коштує…
так, щоб під ключ уже забрати із заміненими шинами,
пофарбувати та відремонтувати, то це приблизно 6 тисяч євро.
Через друзів. Коли уже банка назбиралася,
вона застопорилась, друзі дали уже кінцеву суму
для того, щоб зібрати банку і закупити машину.
Технічне обслуговування вже завершили,
але машину Олегу віддавати не поспішають.
Є ще одна обов'язкова процедура - тест-драйв
на спеціальному майданчику.
Були випадки, коли дві автівки ставимо поряд.
Якщо одна їде швидше, то починаємо шукати,
чого інша так не їде...
І лише після того, як тест-драйв успішно пройдено,
машину віддають військовим. Тепер ця автівка
використовуватиметься на захист України.
Як і Ford, за яким з Бахмута у Київ приїхали військові.
Ця буде у нас завозити БК, виставляти розрахунки,
робити ротацію людей. Дуже добре, що в ній велика
вантажопідйомність. Тобто ми можемо одразу
загрузити багато БК, завезти на позицію й виставити.
Тобто потрібні такі автівки.
На момент виходу матеріалу цей пікап уже воює там, де…
Спекотно. Дуже спекотно.
Ну, ми тримаємося й будемо триматися далі.